texas operation
lone star program has now resulted in
more than 53
000 migrant apprehensions and 3 400
arrests
the program was launched just this march
to combat the smuggling of illegal drugs
and people across the u.s
mexico border texas attorney general ken
paxton
joins us now to react so you look at
those numbers is that a success to you
well it's certainly a beginning and it's
a start to to
a good process but i do not think we can
do this ourselves the federal government
is allowing people just to walk up and
stay and then they get transported
around our state or they get transported
around
other parts of the country but we're
certainly doing what we can to protect
our citizens
and i applaud governor abbott for
instituting this because it is having an
impact
but we can't solve the problems by
ourselves yeah to that federal part of
all this have you heard anything
from the biden white house now that the
lone star numbers have been released
know nothing and actually haven't heard
anything from them since they announced
day one that they were going to allow
people to stay so they've actually been
more about
bringing people in and helping us
prevent people from coming
how much manpower is being used for this
we have we're putting millions and
millions of dollars into this and we've
actually been doing this for years we've
been putting manpower
on the border to help the federal
government so we've just
added manpower there are literally
thousands of people that are working
from our state positions law enforcement
to help the federal government and then
to
do what we're doing now which is arrest
people on our own a.g paxton i ask you
this every time we have you on
i'm going to ask it to you again albeit
in light of the initial part of the
segment where you
reference the number of people that
you've apprehended is the situation at
the border
getting better or is it getting worse
you know i wish i could say it was
getting better but i still think it's
getting worse i think the cartels are
getting more and more strength
uh they've their their networks are
getting better and better as the
administration's opened the border and
so
they're getting better at trafficking
people sex trafficking human trafficking
they make money off of almost every
single person coming up
and then they're getting better at
importing drugs and other illegal
activities and so they're getting
actually
better at it so no the situation is not
getting better because we're not doing
the things that worked
in the trump administration to stop this
switching gears the runaway texas
democrats are going to testify at the
u.s house hearing
tomorrow the hearing is titled democracy
in danger the assault on voting rights
in texas
here's jamie raskin on how brave these
guys are america is facing the most
sweeping assault
on the voting rights of the people since
passage of the voting rights act in
1965 texas is now ground zero in this
battle
and we are honored to have these texas
lawmakers come to testify before our
subcommittee about the struggle to
defend basic democracy
in their state so after this hearing
once this publicity stun is over when do
you guys actually have this
vote on the bill well it's going to
happen it's just a matter of
when they want to come back to texas and
i'm assuming that someday they would
like to come back to texas
but the reality is the irony of this is
that they are the ones stopping voting
they're the ones that are preventing the
democratic process from working
in the in sort of the guise of
protecting voting the reality of this
bill
is actually expands voting in in many
different ways it also tries to prevent
fraud so there is a balance to the bill
but
you know eventually they're going to
come back and and we're going to have a
vote
okay well keep us updated on everything
love to hear from you after that happens
again attorney general ken paxton as
always sir thank you i do have one
follower oh hey
paxton did you send them a care package
with salsa or not
you know i i think i'll just wait till
they get back understood or the sewing
kit and the dr pepper you gotta have it
all hard
hard candy who hasn't lived without a
care package of hard candy a.g paxton
thanks